all right xi jinping
you asked for it
no more mr nice biden
no more mr friendly chocolate chocolate
chip ice cream guy no way
you think that you can just
steal american intellectual property and
take american
manufacturing and and take over
semi-sovereign states
and
run concentration camps to genocide your
own people
and start a global pandemic and shut
down the whole world for a couple years
without consequences
i don't think so buddy jen
tell them what we're going to do
the biden administration will not send
any diplomatic or official
representation to the beijing 2022
winter olympics and paralympic games
given the pierre scenes ongoing genocide
and crimes against
humanity in xinjiang and other human
rights abuses the athletes on team usa
have our full support we will be behind
them 100 percent as we cheer them on
from home we will not be contributing to
the fanfare of the games u.s diplomatic
or official representation would treat
these games as business as usual in the
face of the prc's egregious human rights
abuses and atrocities in xinjiang and we
simply can't do that as the president
has told president xi standing up for
human rights is in the dna of americans
we have a fundamental commitment to
promoting human rights and we feel
strongly in our position and we will
continue to take actions to advance
human rights in china and beyond
we're going to continue to take big
actions like
a diplomatic boycott of the olympics
you know like we're still going to send
all the players and stuff and we're
still going to totally participate in
the olympics
but we're not going to send any
government employees which means that
you
you don't get a photograph with pete
buddha judge take that jinping if you're
like me you put off getting your
christmas presents until the last minute
and then you think oh what am i going to
get my wife and then i actually have
done this you google
gifts to get your wife or you go gifts
to get your dad or gifts together and
you know okay how about a gift that
everyone will love i'm talking about
recons which i actually did give to my
dad a couple of christmases ago and then
i had one for myself i was so excited i
got my raycons they were great they
sound great they're super sleek looking
come in lots of cool different colors
they don't have those little stems
sticking out that make you look like a
bug really high quality earbuds and they
start at a much lower price point than
some of the competitors but i don't have
them anymore because my wife
took them from me so maybe this year for
christmas maybe i'll get myself a few
more pairs
the price is so low and reasonable you
could do that you can get a pair and a
spare this christmas season knock out
that gift list avoid the last minute
shipping scramble
especially with all the supply chain
nonsense head on over and get 15
site-wide with code holiday
i d h-o-l-i-d-a y at buy raycon dot com
slash knowles canada view l e s that
website buy raycon dot com slash knowles
head over there right now use code
holiday to get 15
off your friends your family your loved
ones and you will thank me the
diplomatic boycott of the chinese
olympics
is
a completely meaningless gesture
it does not scare china in the least it
does not have any consequences for china
if the united states
kept the players away from the olympic
games that might have some effect it
would certainly tarnish the credibility
of the olympics it would certainly uh
take down the ratings the ratings would
not be as strong
but
but withholding some diplomats and some
cabinet officials or and pete but a
judge it's not
not going to do anything it's it's
it almost would have been better if the
united states had done nothing at all
but to go out and say as gensake did
there is a genocide going on in china
the leader of china is slaughtering
whole races of people in concentration
camps
and then
to
move forward with this weak meaningless
action it's worse than doing nothing at
all and it sends the message that the
united states is not serious
does does anyone really believe that if
really when
china goes into taiwan china goes into
the united states interests in the south
china sea that the u.s is going to go
send in the marines does anyone believe
that does anyone think
after pulling out 20 years of war in
afghanistan after all the wars in the
middle east does anyone really think
that the american people want to go to
war
in asia
to save taiwan or some other island no
no no one really believes that xi
jinping doesn't think that
is this is the weakest possible response
from an administration that is
extraordinarily weak
hey you
hey hold on you don't know don't go
anywhere yet
it's nice to see you i'm glad you came
by this video and watched it if you want
to see more videos you got to subscribe
you got to ring that bell and even
beyond ringing the bell here which you
should do you got to go over to apple
podcasts spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast it
takes two seconds you pull out your
phone you type in the michael knowles
show subscribe maybe leave a five-star
review i don't know subscribe we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]